there's a new show
I'll probably watch some of it it's on
TLC it's making the rounds right now set
your cues
put it in your calendar
MILF manner
[Music]
life has given me some curveball I think
it's my time to find love
I was married for 14 years I want to get
a chance to do me a little young men
have much more energy they think out of
the box I want that
especially in the bedroom
I am in this amazing beautiful mansion
here in Mexico this is a perfect place
to find love
welcome to the Villa you're about to
embark on a dating experience like none
other oh let's go I have an extremely
high libido is that too much Shane I
have an extremely high libido should I
just said hi libido
ah ladies where's all the men
Ace tonight I'm ready to connect with
somebody who doesn't really care how old
I am
I'm just looking to have fun
here we go
what the hell
it just got real
this is trash TV at its absolute finest
I probably won't watch it only because I
don't subscribe to cable but if I did I
I probably would watch it okay this is
really reality TV just at its absolute
Peak but it's trash it's really really
disgusting and it that last line there
is quite telling she said this just got
real
be and it did just get real and the
whole premise of the show
because these are MILFs I won't go
through the whole initialism or the
whole acronym but the first
the first letter there refers to
moms mothers and so this this is getting
kind of real because it's not just these
young people who think that they have no
consequences in their lives and they
they really don't have a lot of
accountability in their day-to-day
social life and so they go out and it's
the real world or it's the Jersey Shore
or something like that these are these
are people with children that are
supposed to have families that they're
raising that do have responsibilities to
children and they're what they're
they're on some Island in a manner for
the express purpose of
whoring around right basically they're
taking money they're being paid to go
engage in weird kind of degenerate
sexual performances with young guys on
camera that that does get kind of real
that's that's actually different from
the other TV shows that do exactly the
same thing because these are mothers
these are people that that kids are
looking up to and and it's it's deeply
scandalous more scandalous even than
other than trash TV but the other thing
that that makes MILF Manor noteworthy
and and that tells you so much about our
culture that we're living in today and
why we're even talking about it is
because the premise is absurd
young men generally speaking don't want
to sleep with older mothers generally
speaking maybe there's a few guys out
there who that's
you know de Gusty boost no disputanda
Mast but generally speaking that's not
real
if the show were in the reverse if the
show were older guys who leave their
wives and then sleep with younger women
that would be a normal thing it's not
I'm not saying it's a good thing but
that does happen that happens a lot
you you see a lot of couples where
there's an older guy and a younger woman
you see very very few couples where it's
an older woman and a younger guy and I
think that is part of why TLC is pushing
this sort of thing
because this is what our culture does
now
our culture subverts expectations
transgresses Norms left and right
does this
all the way at the White House with the
colors and the definition of marriage
and the way that the officials dress our
culture does this in what is taught in
the schools and the universities our
culture does this at pretty much every
turn
even in reality TV
the fact that I mean now you look at
advertisements for lingerie
advertisements for clothing it used to
be that you would have really really
physically beautiful people modeling
clothing now it's the opposite
and it's it's a political movement
they say yeah we're going to get the
most out of shape models that you ever
saw we're going to have them put it up
we're going to cultivate a cult of
ugliness I mean at every turn you see
uh wickedness substituted for goodness
our culture no longer
values goodness and virtue but quite the
opposite actually in in our popular
culture you don't see the art and TV
shows and books and movies elevating
Heroes it's always anti-heroes it's
always guys who are really bad in the
end you think of the popular age of TV
Tony Soprano Walter White Don Draper
uh Saul Goodman all I mean I could the
list goes on and on and on of all the
great it's always anti-heroes
and you see the culture elevating
ugliness over Beauty
it's probably a pretty funny TV show
because of how absurd that is but it's
it is partaking in its own little corner
of the exact same subversion and
upending of reality that you are seeing
everywhere else it is absurd
rest of the show continues now you do
not want to miss it if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
foreign